my favorite episode of the season is
episode six i think crosstalk
storytelling is so refined but a beat
for you
in that that really landed very well for
me is the stuff that happens on the road
so i wanted to ask you about shooting
shooting that material but
in particular kind of nailing the the
dialogue
less beats of her realizing she
just killed someone that episode is a
really important one because it makes
her
realize how far
she's going in in um
keeping herself safe maintaining her
objective
to take down vaught and
also it it really wakes her up to
realize
um i think she's kind of been in denial
about how much
this world and being in bot has changed
her you know
if we think back to episode one season
one of
annie or starlight we all know that that
would have
not been a feasible thing for her at all
and i think the way she digests the
death and that she
causes it and what's going on in that
episode
is it's a really hard pill for her to
swallow
and i think it's what ultimately you
know i think a lot of the season is
about her
building up that facade to go covert but
also
she's got a wall up in terms of huey and
her mom because she's had her heart
totally broken and i think when you got
when you have someone who is
young and ignorant merely because
they've not yet been exposed to
certain aspects of our world and they
have their trust
betrayed it can um put up a really thick
wall i know that happened for me
personally and i know that
um oftentimes you compensate with a wall
that's too thick and you have to slowly
find yourself
again and your trust in other people and
i think that that episode
and the dash she causes makes her
realize how far she strayed from herself
i think that she knows that cert certain
things have to be done
i think she thinks that it did have to
be done but i think that it's the
beginning of her
starting to find herself again after all
of her
deep heartbreaks and season one and her
exposure to this
immensely dark world her facade and
walls have become
excessively thick and she's then
you know she sets out to find the in
between between being not naive or
ignorant but also being her true
good self